[Musique]
dans le village c'est une institution
est forcément dans le berry la fête de
la pomme de terre commence par la
galette les galettes vp vu combien la
voile et un bouton 75 tôt la veille à 24
par par tall dans le doubs les statuts
des en arrive presque à 2000 chaude ou
froide les gourmands attendent leur part
josiane et fille de boulanger il est
temps de mon papa c'était une pâte
feuilletée et une de purée de pommes de
terre du fromage du persil ou c'est la
tradition c'est le terroir alors je me
dépêche mais avant que n'ait plus ces
deux pattes et des rois et le roi des
pâtes et
les patates ont poussé dans les champs
de laurent c'est sa première récolte
d'habitude il produit des noisettes
je suis très content de ma récolte est
donc la voilà la sécheresse
pour moi non je les ai planté au bon
moment j'ai eu de la chance
dans le stand voisin exceptionnellement
il est permis de jouer un peu avec la
nourriture ici un compétiteur pour la
plus longue les plus sûres on fait du
mieux qu'on peut
voilà exactement
je n'exerçais dans l'année rendez vous à
l'année prochaine
là une candidate pour la plus haute
pyramide
au milieu de la place c'est le moment du
défilé des tracteurs tous des renault
des pièces de musée il faut les protéger
mais gardez garden patrimoine cette
année 60 61 62 et pendant que les petits
imitent les grands sur des modèles
réduits d'engins agricoles
les officiels rend hommage à un certain
louis laurent décédé juste avant de
covile le voici il a créé la fête de la
pomme de terre mais pas seulement
on voit ce qu'il en est maintenant avec
ce parc qui accepte les intentions même
de tubercules au jury des pommes de
terre le pépiniériste fait et
collectionner des dahlias autre plante à
tubercule
il en avait 400 variétés il y en a fait
un jardin il a aussi créé un pavillon du
pérou terre natale de la patate et
chaque année l'amicale fait pousser
éveil surcoût de 100 variétés d'europe
de quoi nourrir le corps et l'esprit
[Musique]